uk tourism is the most depressing thing
on earth like it's just [ __ ]
what would you recommend to someone
who's never been to the uk i when people
come to the uk
[Music]
no no no go go to london but i don't
think right is that the reason why i
think the uk works as a tourist
destination is because you don't know
anything about it yeah you know about
the uk it's this terrible place i think
most people's imaginations of the uk is
the queen harry potter and
well the thing is if you go to london
you get a very sanitized view of london
of the uk and you can have a great time
because you you only see london right
london is like very well kept the
charming part yeah it's very well you
know all the [ __ ] money's in london
i'd say some of some of the countrysides
are pretty good as well which is why i
really appreciate it when i meet people
who like love castles and love going
around whales and stuff like that i'm
like nice
nice yeah yeah honestly if you want to
go to the countryside though i'd say
ireland is better island's [ __ ]
beautiful i've been to the countryside
found out that people just didn't live
near castles i thought that was weird
when i first found that out yeah i lived
near three castles growing up and i was
like see like out of context that sounds
so [ __ ] privileged
why what what are you gonna do with it
what's not my castle but that's the
thing but that's the thing like it's
it's like it's like that if you said
that to a japanese person they'd be like
what are you like the prince of wales no
it's just because you know you there's
so many [ __ ] castles in the uk one of
them was very dangerous and run down and
like climbing it was just like a safety
hazard i don't know how it still allowed
you to go right dude but you know
there's there's one really cool castle
in me it's like called
i feel whales to castles is very much
japan to temples yeah yeah maybe you
know because like i think if you said to
someone who has like no idea of like
asian culture or anything like that and
said like oh yeah there's like three
temples around my house they'd be like
whoa you're [ __ ] bougie japan did
have a lot of castles they were burnt
down well yeah most
there is one in there's a really big one
in what kochi there's a massive one yeah
a lot of them though are recreations
yeah yeah that were like built much much
later i think there's only like a
handful of castles like from that time
that are still standing well a lot of
the ones in the uk are run down as well
like the the out of the three near me
one of them is well kept and that's
mainly for tourist reasons right and the
other two are completely run down and
just like but it's cool that it's a
bunch of rubble
but you can buy that right like you can
purchase that as properties some of them
the big ones you can't they're normally
heritage sites so you can't buy them
they're like public and at that point
people who buy just buy for flex because
who actually lives in a castle nowadays
i believe i read something about france
or something as the most abandoned
castles and the most castles for sale
out of it like any country oh really
apparently you can just buy shadows and
castles oh all nonsense that's pretty
bougie all right you say you say uk is
good for
travel or i've never said that well what
did you say you say come to the uk just
go to london go to london okay well okay
genuine question someone someone's
coming to travel to the uk you want to
show them you want to show them british
culture what did you say what did you
take them to first of all the one
question you have to ask someone who
comes to the uk do you drink do you
drink course and if you don't you're
gonna have a bad
you love drinking with people you can
have a two-week trip and you have a
great time yeah if you don't drink
alcohol
here's a three-day criteria if you don't
drink alcohol i hope you like castles
you know i genuinely think because you
can do nearly everything in london
that's worth seeing in one day like one
or two days one or two two two two
right but but you know like all the
major things are within walking distance
do you take them to like the tourist
tourist sites and everything like that
yeah very fast i'm like here's booking
in palace have a look all right here's
the big ben have a look it's [ __ ] don't
pay it it's like ninety dollars to go on
it rip off don't do it when we when it
was in [ __ ] scaffolding yeah yeah
right so i didn't even get to see it all
right sorry london nice [ __ ] big ben
looks pretty cool actually i like it oh
my god but you know normally it's like
you want to see big ben we can we can go
and drink in the park in front of big
ben yeah and do that yeah that's cool
you know there's the arcade that's now
closing it's closed now yeah
is that the one with shrek at the front
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's it's like it was like yeah that's
an arc there's a namco fanscape there
was a [ __ ] arcade right that's closing
but it was the only arcade um what else
can you do in london um
maybe take them on the boat
on the boat so you know how like you
know there's public transport there's
the tube part of the network is a boat
there's a oh like like a ferry system
that you can just cross the yeah they go
from uh i think greenwich to westminster
yeah uh yeah greenwich i really like
taking people to granite scrunch is a
really nice area you can go and i can be
like look here's where time started
yeah that's all i know about greenwich
oh it's a very nice area actually it's
really well done um there's like a
warship in belfast
in front of the united states like six
hours away you can't go to the
battlefield the the the warship the uh
the uh
it's right in front of the uh house the
uh
what's that right right next to the
bridge uh greenwich stock ridge um the
uh where where the other were you
talking about the sss belfast yeah oh
that one i i don't know don't know that
one either
if you go to greenwich as well there's a
massive boat that's been restored on
land
ship it's [ __ ] massive damn um
the uk government should hire me i'll
make criteria i'll make uh what would
you add
um spoons gonna weather spoons
tesco meals
honestly i would take them spoons
yeah
we went to the shrek arcade in spoons oh
we went to the uh [ __ ] uh gaming bar
as well
like gaming mode
it was literally just a pub with a wii
in it
you really came in that far british
culture man you're just so sick because
like pubs in london are like where all
the best food are as well yeah all the
best food that pub did have some good
food because because the way i see it
right because the way i see it when i go
travel to a place i very rarely want to
go to the big tourist spots right i
don't know
i want good place i want cool places to
see but just like not the here here's
just a landmark that uh everyone takes a
[ __ ] picture around i just want cool
local places and like as someone who
lived in london for like close to three
years if it doesn't revolve around
alcohol i don't know the cool places to
take people oh there's this afternoon
tea afternoon oh afternoon tea and
actually that the home of afternoon tea
yeah of course of course of course i
completely forgot about afternoon that's
pretty much the only part of like
british food that i'm just like yep
afternoon tea [ __ ] slaps um to be
fair i feel australia would be the exact
same thing if it wasn't for the fact
that we have some of the best beaches in
the world
like because because it's like because
like at least we can take you to the
beach you got it easy man yeah but like
if but if you don't like beaches then i
hope you like drinking because we're
gonna be doing a lot of that yeah it's
kind of hard i've had friends
normally americans you're like no i
don't drink it i'm like i honestly don't
know what to do yeah
i can show you big ben
yeah i i have the same thing when i when
like friends come to australia i have to
take them around like a couple times i'm
like do you want to see
the opera house i swear
i'm not an alcoholic but it's just the
culture
i don't know what to do
that's kind of why i wanted to move out
of england because it just felt like if
you didn't drink then there was nothing
else to do to have fun or like just just
like chill out that's a big thing
no one does anything on weekdays in the
uk like weekdays are strictly for
working and then going home and being
depressed that's all you do i feel
that's no one goes out in the uk it's
always the weekend
oh really like even after work no one
really goes out really
yeah
it's normally older people they normally
will go after the pub after work when
they're like 40s because they sit
some people
go to the pub after work no i know i i
if i've worked in an office i would love
to go but i was a youtuber no no one
wanted to go out in the weekdays all
right
it was an absolute uphill battle trying
to get people to do anything in the uk
you have to wait till the weekend yeah
so i never did anything during the
weekend i just worked on videos i think
and played video games i don't really
know what i did
i don't know what i did in london what
did i do what did i do in london i don't
know i went to coffee we have really
good cafes
do we yeah we do
compared to europe
we are we were in europe you guys are
europe we were europe well we're not
we're not in europe anymore because it's
easy to get stuff from like italy and
whatever that's true that's true that's
one thing i miss about that sucks about
japan is that importing anything from
europe is like 20 times the price well
yeah it's like a block of cheese that i
would pay 10 pounds for in the uk
imported from france is now which is
seen as like a luxury expensive [ __ ]
first time i was in australia like
literally
on the side of the planet it's
depressing i i bought a wine bottle and
i looked at it and it was like 30 pounds
in the uk yeah and it was like 90 pounds
here in japan